So, Katherine, we've been working
on this course for a while.
>> I know, Kunal.
And it's about to launch so
I'm really excited.
>> Right.
It's been a couple of months that
we've been designing this course, and
I want to be in perfect synch with you.
>> Okay.
>> Around who the learner or
the student of this course is.
>> Yeah.
So I think
the learner is someone who's
never programmed before.
>> Wait.
When you say never,
you mean no lines of code.
>> Zero.
>> Zero lines of code.
>> Yeah.
>> Wow that's going to
be a tough course for us to design but
it's going to open up the gambit for
everybody to take this course.
>> Absolutely.
I think that's why it's so powerful.
because at the end of this course,
I think they should be able to build
a couple of simple Android apps.
>> Wait, let's backtrack a little bit.
So, we're saying no lines of code,
no programming experience but
we're still saying you need a computer
and you need an internet connection.
>> Yeah, and to have some familiarity
with using a computer and a smart phone.
>> So you browse the internet let's
say on a smartphone or a computer?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay, well let's say this is where
the student is right now, right?
And this is where a professional
Android developer is, right?
This is where they're making apps,
they're making money,
they're changing the world.
Let's say this is where we will
get them at the end of our course.
>> I think we can get them to here.
>> Okay, so in this journey that
the student is taking with us,
what sort of apps
are they building here?
>> Yeah, so
the first app is a birthday card app.
>> Wait, you said first app,
so there is more than one app?
>> Yeah, so first there's a birthday
card app, where they can make it for
someone that they love.
>> I like that.
People have birthdays.
Sometimes they even have half birthdays.
[LAUGH]
>> Yeah, and
the second app should be
a coffee ordering app.
>> So you say, I want two cappuccinos,
and two cappuccinos appear
magically from the phone?
>> Not quite.
But it captures what
the user wants to order and
then it sends it off in an email.
>> Okay.
So in this journey that we've been
sort of dreaming up, how long will it
take the student so they can
budget their time appropriately?
>> Hopefully, 20, 25 hours.
>> I think that's about right.
It'll take a lot of deliberate practice.
They'll make a couple of fun apps.
But what they can do is they
can take this 25 hours and
split this up into 4 or
5 weeks worth of their time.
>> Yeah, I think that sounds good.
>> So that's as much about
the course and about us.
At this point,
I want to ask our students a question.